So another person who might or
might not have Corona virus,
thanks to a super spreader, Donald Trump is
his sort of sometimes lawyer, Rudy Giuliani.
I genuinely don't know if Rudy Giuliani is still
Donald Trump's lawyer. What I do know is Rudy
did an interview on Fox News last night and he
just couldn't stop coughing throughout. And he's
insisting he's still waiting on a corona virus
test that a few days ago he had a negative corona
virus test. You have to see this. Not only can
Rudy not stop coughing, he's sweaty throughout the
entire interview. His eyes are half closed. But
that's common for Rudy in these later afternoon
or early evening interviews, for reasons we've
previously discussed. It may or may not be related
to whatever Rudy is fighting off here. Listen
to this first video. This does not sound good.
Oh, everybody questions the
polls pretty consistently. Oh,
everybody questions the polls pretty consistently.
I almost feel like I need to wear a mask just
watching this. Here's another one.
The scientists say, OK,
he is going to the scientists say, OK, he is
going to the scientists say, OK, he is going.
And then here's a third one you can
actually see. Fox anchor Martha MacCallum
sort of grimace when Rudy Giuliani coughs.
I think they will realize that they
accomplished more that way. But the reality
is, I hear that response. Joan is going to
listen to the experts and bigeye guy and be
determined. The president going to do it.
So, again, people being sick is not funny. The
fact that Donald Trump himself and everybody
around him seems to be at particular risk because
of the behavior they've chosen to engage in and
ridiculing masks and all of it. It's certainly
ironic, but it's never funny when people are sick.
It wasn't just the coughing, by the way, that
was notable. It was also what Rudy Giuliani said.
Here's a very hoarse sounding Giuliani saying
that Trump really has learned a lot from having
coronavirus that you're talking about, where
it becomes, you know, maybe ridiculous driving
by yourself in a car with one eye.
But do you think that this this whole
experience for the president will change
the way he looks at it a little bit?
Sure, things like this do change. I think
he indicated that that he's been educated.
I don't think we have to wait and see exactly
the conclusions that he's drawn from. But I
know he's drawing some conclusions from what
what he's what he's gone through. And there's
a balance here to be struck between wearing a
mask and wearing a mask to the point of almost,
you know, political theater or or maybe even
worse than that fear, an irrational fear.
Why does Trump have to get covered to learn
about it and change his view? It's sort of like
when the. And why does an anti-gay Republican
only realize that their policy has hurt people
when their kid comes out as gay or their
niece comes out as bisexual or whatever
the case may be? Why can't they empathize?
Why aren't they capable of abstract thought?
Everything is on it. I got it. Oh, it's serious.
Now, here is Rudy Giuliani on some aimless rant
about doctors versus scientists. And
doctors aren't scientists, and it's all
just really, really weird.
What would you say to Joe Biden there?
Well, I would say that to Joe that you don't
really understand what scientists are. First of
all, listen to your doctors. That's for sure. They
know your personal history. Doctors really aren't
scientists when they're scientists almost always
have competing opinions. That's what scientists
about. Science isn't a didactic, dogmatic
religion. So there's almost almost every principle
of this kind of science. You know, medical science
has conflicting opinions. And, for example,
it isn't science to be wearing that mask.
Joe, when you're giving a speech and the
people are 30 or 40 feet away from you.
The only thing you can affect when you
when you're doing that is a teleprompter
that's closer to you. So I see through you.
Who is this interview even targeted at? Right.
I mean, when you think of like, who are they?
What is the point of sending Rudy Giuliani out
at this point, particularly coughing like this?
Why would you go and do an interview with such
a terrible cough waiting for a corona virus test
when the president has coronavirus? It's maybe
I don't understand the psyche of the Trump ist
of the Fox News viewer. Maybe I don't understand
the propaganda value of sending Rudy Giuliani out
there anyway. Coughing is the R.. Trump is going
to see this and say, wow, what a strong Giuliani,
even with the cough, even maybe with Corona virus,
if that's what it is he has, he's still going and
doing TV interviews like are they that deluded
that they would not think about the fact that
Trump is spreading this like wildfire to people
around him, that Rudy, if indeed he has Corona
virus, is contagious and he's at a studio.
It seems that maybe that's a home studio. I
don't know. But it seems like a studio. It would
that not computer. Let me know what you think.
Cancel, you know, stay home, send
somebody else. It's absolutely vile